- Environ 200 pêcheurs r r r r s
ce matin devant les bureaux de
l'Union des pêcheurs des
Maritimes, à Shediac.
C'est le tiers de toutedededede
du Détroit de Northumberland.
À un prix avoisinant les 5 $
la livre de homard, ils estiment
qu'il leur coleleleleleleleleler
à quai.
MARC DAIGLE, pêcheur de homard
- Le prix aujourd'hui serait pas
supposé
la livre. C'est pas rentable
sous ça.
STEPHANE JAILLET,
quai de Saint-Édouard
-
temps qu'on aille un prix, puis
c'est pas vrai que 4,50 $, c'est
acceptable. Moi, si qu'on n'a
pas 6 $, je lève mes cages.
saison, combinés à la hausse
du coût de la vie et des tau
d'intérêts, mettent sérieusement
en danger la survie de certaines
Comme l'explique le capitaine
Josh Arseneau, 22 ans,uiui a
récemment acheté un bateau.
JOSH ARSENAULT,
- Ça ne regarde pas bien.
Ça ne se pa p pas pour sûr
à 4,50 $, un gars "run" dans
le trou. Ça ne "feel" pas bien
coûte de l'argent pour
travaill. . C'est pas plaisant,
pour sûr.
- L'action des pêcheurs se veutn
des acheteurs, les usines de
trsfsformation, pour hausser
les prix. Une tentative
qui risque de tomber à plat.g,g.
transformateurs homard Maritimes
- Ce genre d'action-là change
en rien les conditions de marché
qu'on observe depuis quatrereres
de marché dans les mois
qui viennent. Donc, on l'a
déjà dit, je comprends
la frustration, on cononononono,
qui est réelle.
- Les usines de transformation,
qui emploient elles-mêmes des
milliers de lelelelelelelelelelk
sont aux prises avec des
inventaires importants
de produits invendus en raison
L'arrêt de la pêche ne va en
rien aider cette situation.
- Les conditions de marché sonts
dans le moment que moi,
mon inquiétude, c'est que si
les usines n'ont pas a a a a a ,
prévisible de produits,
il y en a peut-être qui vont
choisir, si ça dure,
les portes.
LUC LEBLANC, conseiller en pêche
Union p
- Un petit update pour le prix.
Je ne sais pas si vous êtes au
courant, il y a des usines qui
Ça a monté, ça été confirmé
aujourd'hui à 11 urures.
- Petite consolation :
les prix ont légèrement augmenté
aujourd'hui,urururururururururut
pour les pêcheurs.
DENIS SUTTTTE, pêcheur de homard
- C'est ça qu'on parle tout de
suite, on n'y va pas avant lundi
nous autres, puis on trouve
un juste milu.u.
- Les homardiers font, dans une
saison, les revenus de toute une
moins le homard sera abondant.
Chaqujojour est donc compté.
les pêcheurs resteront à quai.
Ici Nicolasteteinbach,
Radio-Canada, Shediac